let's jump into some audience questions
we missed Pat because of the vacation
two weeks in a row of audience questions
and I miss them I missed answering them
and I'm sure the audience did as well
first question is from justine do you
ever wish you completely believed in
religion I've touched on this a little
bit in the past and I've said that there
there's something to me where if I was a
sort of person that would hear religious
doctrine like for example God has a plan
for you God will make sure that
everything right happens in your life
and if you act correctly you look at how
much I'm struggling with this you will
you know have an eternal life in heaven
or whatever if I could truly believe
that even if it weren't true there
probably would be some benefits I mean
it seems like it would absolutely be the
type of thing that is a sort of calming
and positive presence in some way and in
a way I I don't know that envy is the
right word but sometimes I almost feel
like I envy people who can buy into
bullitt religious beliefs in in that way
although then immediately my rational
self says hold on a second
space is a completely inferior
epistemology to the scientific method
and that's not a suggestion that we
discriminate against people who use
faith as an epistemology but I cannot in
any real way allow faith as an
epistemology to substitute what I
understand to be the scientific method
so in some abstract way yeah I think
that the day to day it could be better
if I completely believed in some
religious doctrine but it's just so hard
for me to really take that seriously
well I think the biggest reason that
people want to wholeheartedly believe in
a religion is because oftentimes they
promise you an afterlife yeah and it's
just natural to have a fear of death so
if there is a text or some set of belief
system that ensures you that you'll have
everlasting life after you pass away
yeah that can be very comforting to a
lot of people but I've gotten to a point
now where I think living for eternity
would be even more terrifying than
just to die one day because I've not
I've not existed before before I was
born and you were fine and I was I was
doing okay but to live forever I just
don't know if I could do that yeah I
mean that's getting into sort of other
questions that are specific to
particular religious beliefs and and it
is interesting I mean I think to answer
the question in the way that it was
asked which is do I ever wish I could
completely believe in religion no I
don't think so I think I sometimes
recognize how my day-to-day might be
less concerned about certain issues if I
completely believed in religion but
knowing what I know do I just say I wish
I just completely believed in religion
now I don't have that I think if maybe
someone was in the hospital or something
I think if you may do better to overcome
your disease or whatever ailment you
have if you believe that the world is
working with you to support you and
you'll be able to get over it because it
should write about your outlook in your
mind set aside that I'm one of the
benefits side from the specific
religious beliefs that might be
associated with that and that's where a
lot of the studies that look at the
impact of religion go wrong which is
religion as a sort of overarching
element of life can have positive
influences that are totally separate
from the non evidence based faith
beliefs so for example community when
you know people are praying for you is
it the prayer that might make you
improve or is it the knowledge that
there's a community of people thinking
of you thus your predisposition when
having treatment is more positive and
that's what leads to a better health
outcome so a lot of the studies that
we've seen that talk about the health
impact of religion are not separating
the faith beliefs versus the community
and culture aspects of being part of a
community which could be a church or it
could be something else altogether
yeah I think community is a big part of
it I think fear of death is another I
was raised Catholic and until I was
about 12 or 13 believed it
wholeheartedly because that's all I knew
I hadn't really reached an age where I
thought critically about the matter and
I remember just not wanting to face what
I assumed now is the reality that it's
just
you know a system of beliefs that
there's nothing to prove behind it you
know it's just something ever taking a
leap of faith on ya and without any
direct evidence I shouldn't be inclined
to jump on board with that so that was
something I resisted for a few years in
the transition between being a believer
and a non-believer and now that's
interesting yeah I never really
experienced that because I was always
raised identifying as Jewish but in the
cultural and ethnic perspective my
parents never taught me religious
beliefs so I never experienced that and
it seems like that would be quite an
internal struggle and it seems like in
the Jewish sense because there is both
the religious side and the cultural side
it kind of muddies the waters a little
bit so you can always kind of identify
as Jewish even if you're secular
correct absolutely and in fact Jews are
very secular absolutely regular in the
US all right good question from Justine